tout d'abord je souhaite rappeler que
serval puis barkan ont permis d'éviter
que les djihadistes prennent le pouvoir
ou qu'ils réussissent à établir un
sanctuaire sur une partie du territoire
malien
même si bien sûr les populations sont
toujours exposés au centre du mali à des
violences endémiques mais enfin faut
quand même se souvenir
le premier résultat de cette opération à
savoir que l'intervention française qui
s'est faite à la demande du gouvernement
malien de l'époque c'est toutes les
choses qu'il faut savoir rappeler a
permis donc d'éviter que nous ayons en
plein coeur de ce ca l1 pouvoir rpt
djihadistes qui aurait certainement
influencé l'évolution politique
notamment du maghreb qui est bien proche
par ailleurs cette opération barkan a et
ça a été du reste confirmée au cours des
derniers mois particulièrement a permis
d'obtenir de très nombreux succès
tactique donc nos forces armées ont
véritablement donné le meilleur
d'elle-même des cibles djihadistes de
haut rang pu être neutralisé l'effort
supplémentaire qui a été accompli depuis
le sommet de pau a permis de porter des
coups sévères à l'oeil js l'état
islamique au grand sahara et encore plus
récemment il faut pouvoir saluer les
résultats remarquables ont été obtenus
dans le cadre de l'opération bourrasques
troisièmement il faut bien comprendre
que ces opérations s'inscrivent dans ce
que l'on appelle le temps long c'est à
dire que ce ne sont pas des opérations
est clair comme on a pu en vivre par
ailleurs sur d'autres territoires
il est bien née
et malheureusement fort probable que la
poussée djihadistes reprendre et
immédiatement en cas de départ de nos
troupes avec un risque de plus en plus
forts de contagion vers le golfe de
guinée
donc ce sont des résultats qu'il faut
bien avoir en tête pour mesurer déjà les
efforts accomplis les situations que
nous avons pu éviter et ce qui ne nous
empêche pas de nous interroger celui de
se poser un certain nombre de questions
auxquelles je voudrais venir maintenant
en effet les raisons de ce caractère non
pérenne de nos succès ne sont pas
militaires j'ai évoqué encore une fois
les succès que nous forçons ont remporté
elles sont essentiellement de notre
point de vue politique et
institutionnelle d'une part les progrès
politiques dont dépend la résolution
définitive de la crise sont loin d'être
allé au même rythme que les avancées
militaires
or tous nos collègues ça bien ici qu'il
n'y a pas de solution militaire sans
solution politique
l'accord d'alger n'a été que très
partiellement mise en oeuvre est bien
pire nous sommes en quelque sorte
revenus en 2013 avec le coup d'état
militaire au mali est un processus
démocratique qui repart de zéro et en
tous les cas qui n'est pas assez
lentement de notre point de vue et l'on
sait que l'une des causes essentielles
des difficultés que rencontre ce pays
c'est l'absence d'état l'absence d'état
dans de très vaste zone au nord et au
centre et en l'absence d'état évidemment
on prépare le terreau à toutes les
formes de djihadisme qui se répandent
dans la région par ailleurs les forces
locales les armées locales et notamment
celle du g5 sahel malgré un courage
indéniable est magnifique et malgré les
pertes énormes que ces fortes subies ce
sont encore loin on est là pour se dire
la vérité sont encore loin de prendre la
relève de nos soldats pour affronter les
djihadistes certes l'armée malienne a
progressé l'armée tchadienne entre
depuis bien longtemps
son courage la force conjointe du g5 ça
elle prend lentement ses marques quand
on a eu l'occasion d'y aller on a vu et
des efforts conséquents tu étais encore
accompli depuis mais on sait très bien
que là encore on n'est pas exactement au
niveau qui permettrait de substituer ses
forces locales à la présence française
tout ceci n'est malheureusement pas
suffisant
d'un autre côté le soutien de nos alliés
là aussi on va dire les choses telles
que nous les pensons ici laisse le
soutien de nos alliés n'est pas non plus
celui que nous espérions etc à de
nombreuses reprises nous avons quémander
en particulier la création de la force
takouba à constituer une avance certaine
c'est une avance certaine et c'est bien
car c'est aussi un embryon d'une europe
de la défense que l'on évoque et au
moins une prise de conscience d'un
certain nombre de pays européens que la
sécurité c'est pas simplement de
surveiller la russie d'un oeil mais que
c'est ce qui se passe au sud est aussi
tout aussi inquiétant mais disons les
choses les partenaires européens qui
veulent nous rejoindre ne se bousculent
pas et si je compare de le chiffre des
forces présentes à nos côtés et le fait
qu'en europe on a deux millions de
d'hommes de femmes en sous statut
militaire voyez la différence et on se
sent parfois un petit peu seul même si
encore une fois il convient de saluer
les efforts et personnellement les
efforts que vous avez fait madame la
ministre pour attirer dans ses
opérations à la fois des matériels et
équipements
je pense aux hélicoptères danois
hélicoptère shinook aussi anglais les
nouveaux contingents suédois tchèques
etc qui arrive tout ceci va dans le bon
sens mais j'allais dire que le gros de
l'effort est quand même consenti par les
forces françaises enfin et c'est un
autre sujet dont la non la commission a
la responsabilité
cette fameuse approche 3d diplomatie
défense et développement restent pour
l'instant
de notre point de vue très incantatoire
le développement est d'ailleurs très lié
à la bonne gouvernance qu'il faut bien
le dire avec des mots choisis reste
souvent un voeu pieux et donc madame la
ministre
nos interrogations tournent autour de
ces problématiques parce que je souhaite
le rappeler ici
nous n'oublions pas en ce qui concerne
les parlementaires et notamment les plus
anciens dont je suis que nous avons nous
mêmes une responsabilité dans la
présence de nos forces nous avons voté
la prolongation de quatre mois et même
si d'autres votes ne sont pas intervenus
mais celles et ceux qui ont voté sont
donc quelque part responsable de la
sécurité et de la présence de nos forces
armées
auxerre alors notre principale
interrogation l'alléguait
elle sort de ces constatations la fin de
la crise du sahel dépend in fine est
d'une évolution politique qui va
peut-être mettre des années pour ne pas
dire des décennies car certains experts
nous disent ce sont les affrontements et
dépasse très largement la naissance du
jihadisme et ce sont des querelles qui
sont ancestrales entre certains peuples
certains clans certaines régions et donc
est ce que pendant tout ce temps nous
allons devoir rester engagés dans les
conditions actuelles c'est à dire avec
des milliers d'hommes avec plus ou moins
de 5000 hommes vous allez nous préciser
alors certes circule l'information selon
lequel le président de la république et
vous même allez décider de diminuer de 5
ou 6 enfin je sais pas les chiffres qui
seront au final évoqué ça nous apparaît
j'allais presque dire comme une mesure
de management mais ce n'est pas un
objectif final quel 5 ou 600 hommes
c'est parce qu'ils changent le destin
des des 5000 qui resteront et est-ce
qu'il faut donc pas revoir nos objectifs
politiques et nos objectifs stratégiques
dans un sens plus réaliste et adapter
notre dispositif en conséquence
oui moi j'ai souhaité que cette audition
ait lieu au fond des questions et que ce
débat vous soit utile parce que si c'est
pour faire des constatations qu'on lit
partout nous ont dit les choses telles
qu on les ressent c'est une
interrogation d'autant plus forte
à la suite des événements récents même
si le sondage comme tous les sondages
peut être contesté discuter un récent
sondage fait état d'une opposition
désormais majoritaire des français à
l'opération et les élus qui sont là et
qui viennent de toutes sortes de
territoires peuvent évoquer les
questionnements ont selon le voit sur
les réseaux que faites vous là bas
rapatrier nos hommes forts on connaît
bien et vous les avez aussi ces
questions en écho et puis il ya aussi la
question très lourd du
budget de que cela représente c'est plus
qu'un million par jour
certains parlent 2 millions à millions
en tous les cas c'est une dépense
conséquente pour le budget à un moment
où par ailleurs nos forces sont
évidemment besoin de moyens alors nous
aimerions madame la ministre que vous
puissiez revenir sur cette question des
objectifs politiques de cette opération
même si nous avons bien conscience
qu'ils relèvent aussi pour une bonne
part de l'action diplomatique de la
france et des initiatives du président
de la république lui-même mais nous nous
lions les deux débats parce que sans ça
si c'est uniquement sur le la la
constatation des efforts militaires
nous les saluons et nous leur rendons
hommage et on trouve qu'effectivement
ils font ce qu'il ya de mieux en la
matière mais encore une fois c'est en
termes politiques que cette opération
doit doit trouver une solution
la décision de retrouver le niveau des
effectifs d'il ya un an qui semble déjà
prises ne semble pour notre part
constitue à elle seule la stratégie et
qu'est ce qui va se passer si dans un an
si dans un an le mali n'a pas avancé
d'un pas vers une solution politique
globale
qu'est ce qui va se passer est ce qu'on
sera peut-être plus de morts plus de
blessés et avec une classe politique
malienne qui nous paraît assez étanche à
la nécessité d'organiser plus sévèrement
et plus radicalement la concertation et
la réconciliation nationale
car finalement la problématique est bien
cela et donc la question que l'on vous
pose c'est est ce que au sommet ne
djamena dont on attend beaucoup
un certain nombre de conditions de
conditions réelles vont être posées à
nos partenaires ou bien est-ce qu'on va
rester dans cette espèce de sentiment
sur lequel les dirigeants africains
souhaitent que notre présence demeure
mais il n'accomplit ce pas eux mêmes les
efforts que l'on est en droit d'attendre
de leur part faut assumer cette
réconciliation nationale quant à la
modification du dispositif est ce qu'on
peut imaginer une forme de présence
préservant nos intérêts à long terme
tout en ménageant davantage la vie de
nos soldats jeu
vous les 10 ha puis j'ai repris je
disais hier encore au gnr c'est très
agréable sur une audition dans ces
conditions eric vous pouvez voir ce qui
convient est ce que c'est une question
très importante qui est beaucoup plus
matérielles je pense que du reste nos
collègues y reviendrons en charge et de
tout cela est-ce qu'en matière de
sécurité tous les efforts sont faits
pour assurer à nos équipes qui partent
notamment dans ces convois meurtrier
enfin dans ces convois qui enregistre le
plus d'accidents
est ce que l'on fait tout est ce qu'on
utilise les meilleurs matériels les
meilleurs blindage 1
est ce qu'il n'ya pas là un réexamen
profond à faire pour que on utilise des
matériels qui protège au maximum le
risque n'est pas zéro mais qui protège
au maximum la vie de nos militaires dont
nous sommes collectivement comptables
ici colonel important a plaidé devant
nous pour un engagement moins visibles
on connaît ses prises de position qui du
reste a frappée plus fort si la menace
dépasse à nouveau un certain seuil
on peut se poser également la question
de notre présence au tchad
est ce qu'un redéploiement ne
supposerait pas de réactiver une forme
d'opération épervier puisqu'en fait
barkan a absorbé l'opération épervier
d'autres questions ne peuvent être élus
d'éluder nos militaires en particulier
les forces spéciales est ce qu'elle ne
perde pas au sahel
l'expérience de la très haute intensité
enfin ça c'est on est vraiment d'europe
dans le creux de l'actualité
d'aujourd'hui qu'elle sera de nouveau de
votre point de vue là proches de la
nouvelle administration byden sur ces
questions puisque on sait très bien que
on a véritablement besoin d'un appui
tactique et logistiques importants de la
part de la part de nos amis américains
voilà quelques questions il y en aura
certainement d'autres dans le débat
merci encore une fois d'avoir accepté ce
débat qui ne se veut absolument pas
offensif à l'endroit du gouvernement et
singulièrement pas votre endroit parce
que vous je sais le combat que vous
menez à la fois pour la sécurité de nos
troupes vos visites fréquentes les
conditions d'information que vous êtes
très informés de ce qui se passe et mais
je pense que le parlement ne peut pas
rester absent de ce sujet parce que on
peut se souvenir du syndrome qui avaient
frappé l'opinion publique au lendemain
des tristes événements d'afghanistan ou
brusquement l'opinion a décroché et a
quasiment exiger du président de la
république de l'époque de se dégager de
l'afghanistan est donc là on sait les
conséquences que cela peut avoir moi je
dis souvent regarder une carte
géographique regarder si jamais le mali
tongs ce qui se passe tout autour tout
autour au nord c'est juste la frontière
sud de l'europe et de la france ce qui
n'est quand même pas négligeable
donc voilà pourquoi ensemble et dans la
profondeur j'allais dire du débat nous
souhaitons poser les vraies questions à
voir vos éléments de réponse pour que ce
débat du 9 octobre auquel le président
et la conférence des présidents qui
s'est tenue tout à l'heure vient
d'accorder exceptionnellement à droite
parole de tous les groupes donc on va
avoir le débat habituel c'est-à-dire les
seize questions à deux minutes
enfin l'intervention de la commission
puisque c'est la commission qui a
demandé le débat mais après donc
exceptionnellement les groupes vont
pouvoir s'exprimer avec un temps de
parole ce qui va permettre à chacun de
vous donner l'écho de ce que pensent les
sénateurs qui je le rappelle vous ont
toujours soutenu et ont toujours soutenu
les initiatives du président république
et du gouvernement quant à l'opération
barkan et je précise juste avant de vous
de vous c'est à paroles que nous aurons
une petite question qui n'a strictement
rien qui n'a strictement aussi du rsa
avoirs concerne l'actualisation de la
lpm parce que finalement on n'a pas été
informé de ce qui s'est passé au 31
décembre de cette année
concernant le gel d'un certain nombre de
crédits donc ça c'est mais c'est en
questions diverses
se dire voilà madame amis je vous laisse
la parole et puis après comme nous en
avons l'habitude nous aurons nous
engageons le débat le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs permettez-moi
d'abord de vous renouveler tous mes
voeux de bonne année et en cette
première édition première audition par
don de 7 de cette commission
je voulais aussi vous dire combien je
considérais que cet échange sur
l'opération barkan était légitime
un an après le sommet de pau je crois
qu'on est fait le débat est utile
alors comme vous monsieur le président
vous comprendrez que je ne puisse pas
entamer cet échange avec votre
commission sans rendre hommage à nos
soldats qui consacre et qui donnent leur
vie à ce combat et je ne peux pas
commencer sans évoquer les noms du
sergent-chef yvonne huisne du mais
rachat des logis tannerie maori du
brigadier chef loïc risser deux
brigadiers quentin pocher du brigadier
dorian issakhanian 5 militaire mort pour
la france tomber pour nous protéger
cinq noms qui résonneront à jamais dans
nos mémoires nous leur avons rendu
hommage au début du mois de janvier à
thierville sur meuse puis à haguenau et
je souhaite remercier ceux d'entre vous
qui étaient présents pour leur rendre
cet hommage le temps de l'hommage est
infinie et aujourd'hui je crois qu'on
ait fait le plus bel hommage que nous
puissions leur rendre c'est d'expliquer
au mieux quel est ce combat pour lequel
ils sont tombés et quelle est cette
mission en laquelle il croyait temps je
ne suis pas sûr d'épuiser toutes les
questions monsieur le président que vous
avez posé dans votre propos liminaire
mais je sais que les questions
ultérieure me permettront de compléter
ma réponse je souhaiterais d'abord
rappeler pourquoi nous sommes au mali
depuis huit ans
ça fait donc huit ans que nous sommes
engagés et sur le papier huit années
d'engagement c'est conséquent il ne faut
donc jamais perdre de vue les raisons et
les objectifs de cet engagement
alors je voudrais commencer par quelques
16 simples que vous connaissez par coeur
mais qu'il me semble néanmoins
indispensable de rappeler dans le cadre
de cette audition pourquoi sommes-nous
intervenus au mali parce que les
autorités maliennes
nous on demandé parce qu'en 2013 alors
que des colonnes djihadistes foncé sur
bamako les autorités maliennes nous ont
appelés à l'aide afin d'éviter comme
vous l'avez dit monsieur le président la
chute de leur état et son naufrage dans
le terrorisme islamiste
alors pourquoi après 8 en sommes nous
toujours au mali parce que le mali et
ses voisins le niger le tchad la
mauritanie le burkina faso nous le
demandent toujours ce sont les voeux
qu'ils ont renouvelé sans ambiguïté avec
vigueur au sommet de pau il ya
exactement un an parce que le combattre
le terrorisme au mali et plus largement
au sahel
c'est la deuxième raison c'est protéger
les citoyens français et européens alors
au sahel la france et ses partenaires
ont deux ennemis il s'appelle d'esch et
al qaïda et à vrai dire peu importe les
acronymes et des noms exacts de leurs
filiales locales ce sont bien nos dont
il s'agit deux multinationales du
jihadisme qui n'hésite pas à
déstabiliser les états à soumettre les
populations et à cibler de manière
indiscriminée
civile pour parvenir à leurs fins ce
sont deux multinationales djihadistes
qui veulent aussi combattre la france et
les français
partout où ils le peuvent comme le
prouve toute leur publication qui sont
des publications haineuse
comme vous le savez il rappelé en août
que ce sont eux qui ont fomenté les
attentats de ouagadougou et de grand
bassam en 2016 les attentats qui ont tué
indistinctement des français des
européens et des personnes d'autres
nationalités des français qui étaient à
la terrasse d'un café qui était en
vacances à la plage
bien qu était là tout simplement pour
travailler des français qui ont été
froidement assassiné d'une balle dans la
tête et voilà leur idéologie mortifère
infligé le règne du chaos et de la
terreur au sahel donc la france se bat
contre des terroristes qui torturent et
qui assassinent des sommes qu'ils
violent des femmes et qui tuent des
enfants
c'est ça la réalité et c'est pour cela
que nous nous battons si des ch et al
qaïda s'empare du sel s'ils en font un
sanctuaire
alors il y à un risque de les voir
s'étendre du sahel à toute l'afrique de
l'ouest
il ya aussi un risque de voir la région
déstabilisée devenir une sorte de base
arrière de multinationales terroristes
qui par ailleurs menace publiquement
notre pays une base arrière où il serait
possible d'entraîner des djihadistes et
de préparer de nouveaux attentats
on a d'ailleurs déjà vu ce que cela a
donné
en afghanistan avant 2001 au levant
avant 2014
et cela c'est évidemment un risque pour
la france et pour l'europe
nous ne voulons pas que le sahel
devienne une sorte d'académie du
terrorisme et c'est parce que nos
partenaires européens partage pleinement
cette évaluation qu'ils s'investissent
chaque jour un peu plus au sahel
chacun selon ses moyens ses traditions
où ces pratiques
cette mobilisation croissante de nos
partenaires européens
ainsi qu internationaux a été accéléré
vous l'avez souligné monsieur le
président par le sommet de pau qui a été
provoqué par le président de la
république il y a un an alors que nous
sortions d'une série de revers et d'
attaques contre les armées maliennes et
nigériennes
ce sommet nous a d'abord permis de
fédérer les volontés les pays du sahel
ont en effet exprimé leur adhésion et
leur détermination politique à conduire
ce combat avec l'aide de la france et
depuis pau l'engagement des sahéliens ne
sait plus démenti ce sommet nous a aussi
permis de mobiliser la communauté
internationale autour des enjeux
sécuritaire au sahel et de la nécessaire
montée en puissance des forces armées
locales ce qui constitue aujourd'hui la
kz majeurs de notre action je vais y
revenir
enfin ce sommet nous a permis d'inscrire
formellement notre action dans une
stratégie globale qui se déroule en
quatre temps ce sont les fameux quatre
piliers du sommet de pau lutter contre
le libre hommes armés terroristes
renforcer les capacités des forces
armées des états de la région appuyer un
retour de l'état sur tout le territoire
et aider au développement
car nous le savons tous nous ne
parviendrons pas à la paix si nous
concentrons uniquement nos efforts sur
les opérations militaires
nous ne pouvons pas gagner une guerre
comme celle ci seulement si je puis dire
en neutralisant les terroristes car avec
le temps il se régénère
nous devons réussir à transformer les
gains tactiques chèrement acquis sur le
terrain en progrès politiques
économiques et sociaux car l'objectif de
l'action militaire c'est de préparer le
terrain et de créer un espace pour
l'action politique et pour le
développement
alors aujourd'hui c'est à dire un an
après le sommet de pau les premiers
résultats sont là la situation s'est
améliorée
je le dis évidemment avec une extrême
prudence
mais néanmoins nous voyons plusieurs
signaux positifs qui doivent nous
encourager et vous m'offrez monsieur le
président la possibilité peut-être
d'exposer un peu plus dans le détail
certaines actions concrètes que nous
menons je voudrais notamment revenir sur
une initiative qui est née du sommet de
peau et qui s'appelle ménaka sans armes
c'est une initiative qui est menée
conjointement par les forces armées
maliennes
les groupes armés signataires de
l'accord pour la paix et la
réconciliation au mali signé en 2015
ainsi qu'avec l'appui des nations unies
et de la force barkan cette initiative
vise à réduire l'insécurité dans la
ville de ménaka la sécurité que vous
connaissez bien car il s'agissait
jusqu'à récemment d'un bastions des
terroristes dans la région des trois
frontières
concrètement des femmes à des forces
armées
yen et des casques bleus patrouillent
dans la ville
il assure une présence à la fois
dissuasive et préventif en ce début
d'année 2021 la population les autorités
les acteurs locaux les partenaires sont
unanimes les résultats de cette
initiative sont encourageants et je vous
livrerai juste une phrase d'un malien
représentant la société civile locale
qui a déclaré à l'agencé france presse
la chose suivante ouvrez les guillemets
avant à ménaka
les gens ne dormait pas ils ne savaient
pas à quoi s'en tenir
maintenant on arrive à dormir
même si la peur persiste
je voudrais maintenant vous dire
quelques mots de la force takouba qui a
été lancé avec nos partenaires européens
en mars de l'année dernière
là aussi où il y beaucoup de choses sur
cette force et je voudrais profiter de
l'opportunité que vous m'offrez pour
décrire peut-être plus précisément ce
que fait cette force comment elle est
organisée comment elle opère c'est donc
une force complètement nouvelle qui est
composé de forces spéciales européennes
qui est destiné à entraîner
puis accompagné les forces maliennes
dans leur combat contre leur contre le
terrorisme alors concrètement comment
cela marche il ya d'une part
l'entraînement
que faisons nous nous partageons nos
savoir-faire notre savoir être les actes
réflexe d'un combattant avec les forces
maliennes
nous les entraînons à se déplacer se
protéger et réagir en cas d' attaque
nous revoyons aussi le maniement des
armes nous les formons au respect des
règles du droit international
humanitaire et du droit des conflits
armés
ce qui est plus novateur c'est
l'accompagnement au combat en trois
temps nous leur apprenons à planifier
une opération à la conduire sur le
terrain et à en tirer une expérience une
analyse après action concrètement nous
combattons ensemble les maliens avant ce
temps binôme avec les militaires
européens les apprennent à utiliser le
réseau radio coordonner les capacités
dont il dispose
planifiez les ravitaillements en eau ou
en essence est évidemment engager une
action de combat contre les terroristes
c'est donc une formation qui est
conduite de bout en bout du premier jour
d'engagement jusqu'à l'épreuve du feu
takouba c'est aujourd'hui huit pays
européens partenaires mobilisés à nos
côtés la suède la république tchèque
l'estonie l'italie le danemark portugal
la belgique et les pays bas
et par ailleurs il faut rappeler que
nous sommes politiquement soutenue par
l'allemagne la norvège et la
grande-bretagne
alors depuis le 15 juillet takouba est
une réalité opérationnelle et a entamé
sa mission auprès des forces armées
maliennes avec un premier déploiement
qui franco estoniens qui est composé
d'une cinquantaine de militaires 28
français 22 estonien est ce
ce ce groupe franco estonien a été
engagé dans des opérations majeures
notamment les dernières que vous avez
rappelé menée par barkan à partir du
mois d'octobre et a elle aussi on lui
aussi participé à la saisie de matériel
des groupes terroristes
le premier baptême du feu de la force a
été réalisée si je puis dire il ya
quelques jours dans la région dans son
go près de la frontière du mali et du
niger
la force en est sortie victorieuse est
par ailleurs le groupe franco tchèque
vient d'achever son déploiement et a
déjà entamé son entraînement avec une
unité malienne il sera d'ailleurs
bientôt engager à son tour en opération
quant au contingent suédois il a
également consomme ont commencé son
déploiement et il monte en puissance il
sera composé d'environ 150 militaires il
sera stationné à ménaka il comprendra
trois hélicoptères de manoeuvre
un avion de transport tactique un groupe
de forces spéciales qui sera donc en
mesure d'intervenir rapidement dans
n'importe quel point de la région des
trois frontières complété d'une équipe
chirurgicale
il sera au complet dans quelques
semaines par ailleurs d'autres
contributions sont annoncées pour les
prochains mois notamment de la part du
danemark du portugal de l'ukraine de la
grèce de la hongrie et de l'italie dont
je voudrais préciser que son parlement a
autorisé en juillet le déploiement d'un
contingent pouvant aller jusqu'à 200
militaires et huit hélicoptères de
manoeuvre l'italie poursuit actuellement
ses travaux de planification en vue d'un
déploiement à partir du mois de mars de
cette année
bakouba vous l'avez compris est et
continuera d'être une priorité pour les
armées en 2021
comme l'est la formation des forces
armées sahélienne en effet là aussi je
voudrais que l'on aurait me remets
morion quelques chiffres car depuis 2014
ce sont dix sept mille soldats du g5
sahel qui ont été formés au combat par
la force barkan dont 6000 au cours de la
seule année 2000 20 c'est à dire trois
fois plus que les années précédentes
alors je ne vous ai pas parlé la force
conjointe du g5 sahel mais je suis
certaine que nous pourrons l'évoqué dans
le cadre de vos questions j'en viens
donc au mot de la fin au sel
la france n'a pas d'agenda caché
nous avons un seul objectif lutter
contre le terrorisme
comme nous le faisons d'ailleurs au
levant alors moi aussi je lis la presse
et je voudrais redire avec force de
vente votre commission que dire que la
france est englué dans une guerre sans
fin est faux nous l'avons dit nous
l'avons répété avec nos partenaires
internationaux
notre présence n'est certainement pas
éternel et nous ne resterons que le
temps nécessaire pour que les forces
armées de nos amis et partenaires
sahélien soit en mesure de mener ce
combat elle même et pas un jour de plus
c'est l'objectif vers lequel nos efforts
collectifs convergent et comme le
président de la république a eu
l'occasion de le dire hier lors de ses
voeux aux armées
je le cite les résultats obtenus par nos
forces au sahel
conjugué à l'intervention plus
importante de nos partenaires européens
vont nous permettre d'ajuster notre
effort nous aurons l'occasion de faire
un bilan complet et détaillé de notre
action lors du sommet de n'djamena
nous aurons l'occasion de discuter avec
nos partenaires et nos alliés des
orientations que nous souhaitons
collectivement donner à notre engagement
pour les mois à venir
aujourd'hui je crois que si nous disions
aux français que leur sécurité serait
mieux prises en compte
si tous nos soldats de barkan rentrait
deux mains si nous disions cela aux
français eh bien je crois que nous ne
dirions pas la vérité même si je leur
dis haut et fort notre présence n'est
pas éternel voilà monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
remercie de votre attention et je suis
évidemment prêt à répondre à vos
questions ainsi que celles que vous
m'avez déjà posée merci ma mamie nice
pour ces exposés qui trace le le cadre
de neutre
réflexion qui réaffirme un certain
nombre de constatations sur lequel nous
sommes d'accord mais certainement on va
aller plus loin comme j'ai un nombre
assez conséquent d'intervenants on va
faire deux groupes pour que les choses
restent quand même à peu près
incompréhensible
donc on va prendre un prendre six
premiers intervenants
cédric perrin merci monsieur le
président la ministre madame lemieux
vous avez commencé votre propre vos
propos rendant hommage à nos militaires
aux enfants de la france qui ont qui
sont tombés pour notre sécurité mais
aussi vous l'avez rappelé je pense que
c'est important pour la protection de
l'europe attire ville sur meuse à
haguenau j'étais présent vos côtés j'ai
vu beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup de
tristesse notamment de votre part j'ai
vu aussi le poids qui pèse sur vos
épaules mais aussi sur nos épaules à
tous et cela évidemment a beaucoup
marqué et je voulais vous remercier pour
les mots justes que vous avez eu à leur
endroit
on avait un ministre je voulais
évidemment abordé des questions plus
matérielles enfin qui ont plus a trait
au matériel le 4 septembre 2010 est aux
universités d'été de la défense à toulon
suite à un rapport que notre commission
avait rendu vous avez un éboulement dans
l'armement des drones vous avez décidé
de permettre cette évolution aujourd'hui
à barkan lusage des drones armés est un
atout évidemment remarquable est saluée
de tous à mon goût un peu trop caché
mais c'est ainsi en tout cas pas
suffisamment mis en avant
cependant nous sommes loin d'une totale
efficacité puisque une autorisation de
vol des deux derniers systèmes blocs 5
n'est pas encore effective et que pour
l'instant ils sont toujours cloués au
sol et que comme l'indiquent le la diapo
qui figure ici seuls trois drones sont
opérationnels
ensuite la livraison du patroller au
61ème régiment d'artillerie et semble
décalé vous l'avais dit à l'assemblée
nationale à 2022 alors ma première
question c'est comment est ce que vous
comptez combler le retard de la france
dans le domaine des drones puisque on a
quand même quelques quelques petits
sujets autres sujets importants
concernant les zones les drones c'est ce
sont les événements du haut karabakh qui
ont vu l'utilisation de drones suicide
turc et israélien
à mi chemin entre des missiles et des
drones l'azerbaïdjan à l'azerbaïdjan
pardon a su se constituer une petite
flotte de drones capables d'effectuer
presque l'émission d'une aviation de
combat mais pour beaucoup moins cher et
parfois pour des pertes humaines moins
importante jamais des drones ont autant
détruit en un seul en une seule campagne
il se démocratise et offre un des
adversaires ayant peu de moyens
la possibilité de se mettre au niveau
depuis les événements du haut karabakh
les doctrines changer les britanniques
notamment évolué vers plus de drones
moins cher alors comment est ce que vous
pensez pouvoir adapter nos systèmes de
défense sol air à cette nouvelle menace
et comment faire face à cette évolution
qui que je pourrais presque parfois
qualifiée de low cost enfin dernière
question c'est de prison nous permet
maintenant la ministre sur un sujet
sensible en ce moment et qui me semble
important d'aborder loin évidemment de
toute polémique
c'est là évidemment lalano perte de deux
militaires sur barkan sont souvent liés
à des idées auxquelles sont confrontés
nos bébés elle or d'après les
informations dont je dispose nouvelle
belle mk1 mais je ne parle pas des
ultima doivent recevoir de nouveaux kits
de blindage contre les mines et les yeux
d or à ce jour aucun n'a encore été
équipés mais les commandes semblent
dater de 2016 l'équipe semble disponible
mais l'industrie semble beaucoup tardé
ou en tout cas a pris beaucoup de retard
je veux vraiment que je souhaite
vraiment qu'on différencie les mk et les
ultimes alger utilise une quinzaine sont
ceux qu'on utilise analyse et ultima
sont ceux que nous devrions percevoir
dans quelques temps évidemment personne
ne peut dire si avec de tel kit kit de
blindage nos bébés l'aurep résisté mais
rien n'a elle ne rien faire ce serait
évidemment en pire que tout on ne peut
que regretter le retard donc pris par
les industries est le sixième mais
informations sont justes et tous les
programmes tous les programmes prennent
du retard mais tous n'ont
potentiellement pas les mêmes
conséquences
voilà les questions que je voulais vous
poser merci beaucoup merci c'est une
question importante qui les rejoint
celle que j'avais posé sur la sécurité
nous sommes notamment pendant les temps
de transport ou la plupart des accidents
sont intervenus olivier cadic alors kate
en séance oui c'est monsieur le
président madame la ministre je veux
tout d'abord vous remercier pour la
force et la hauteur de votre propos
introductif le groupe union centriste
s'associe à l'hommage que vous avez
rendu à nos soldats tombés au combat jeu
également quand c'est le propos par le
fait le groupe union centriste vous
remercie sincèrement pour la décision
courageuse de ne pas autoriser la prise
de contrôle par l'américain teledyne de
la société photonis fleuron froide en
français de la vision nocturne
je voudrais également vous sensibiliser
sur la suppression envisagée alité par
le mr l'intérieur du poste d'expert
fraude et immigration à douala
ce serait un point d'affaiblissement
majeur car le poids port de douala
dispose d'une importance stratégique en
manière de logis sans matière de
logistique pour approvisionner nos
forces armées au sahel comme j'ai pu le
constater en décembre dernier à faya
largeau puisqu'il s'agit d'une décision
interministérielle je relaye
l'inquiétude émanant de notre poste
diplomatique au cameroun pour que vous
puissiez alerté le ministre de
l'intérieur sur les effets
potentiellement négatifs de ce choix
lors de ma visite de la zone de
commandement barkan à n'djamena le mois
dernier j'ai eu l'opportunité de saluer
nos forces pour leurs remarquables
résultats obtenus face au terrorisme en
2020 et rendu hommage à leur sacrifice
et leur dévouement quotidien
nos militaires soulignent l'engagement
collectif au sahel où la france n'est
pas seule à agir
grâce à l'impulsion donnée par le
président de la république
le sahel est aujourd'hui un laboratoire
pour permettre à l'union européenne de
démontrer sa capacité à peser sur le
rétablissement de la paix et de la
sécurité et nos populations conseil
formation militaire vous l'avez évoqué
engagements opérationnels qui sait que
l'allemagne par exemple compte près de
1000 hommes engagés dans la mini semant
la france est aussi engagée aux côtés
des armes et du g5 scellent leur
connaissance du terrain et des
populations locales est fondamental pour
rétablir la paix dans la région
apaiser les séparatismes et chasser le
terrorisme
mes interrogations sont simples huit ans
après le début de l'opération barkan
quel regard portez-vous sur le niveau
d'implication des forces armées des pays
du g5 sel quels sont les progrès
concrets que vous avez observé dans
leurs engagements opérationnels
je remercie jeu
intervenant bien calibré son propos de
telle sorte que la longue liste
d'intervenants puissent être évoquées
que la ministre ait le temps de répondre
dans le temps qu'elle nous a party
madame raymond pas verrou par
visioconférence ah non pardon c'est
olivier cigolotti non non je m'étais
trompé de bolivie cigolotti puis après
isabelle qui se prépare qui prépare son
matériel
merci président merci madame la ministre
de votre présence parmi nous cet après
midi pour évoquer un sujet qui est
important pour l'ensemble des groupes
politiques de notre de notre assemblée
l'histoire de ces dernières décennies
madame la ministre ou démontre qu'il est
difficile pour des forces
conventionnelles pour des forces
occidentales de remporter des victoires
importantes dans des conflits
asymétriques
les exemples sont nombreux qu'il
s'agisse du vietnam de l'indochine de
l'aghanistan que vous avez cités dans
votre propos introductif au sel le
conflit originelle s'est transformé en
une pluralité parfois de conflit
interethnique et parfois localiser
difficile effectivement comme vous
l'avez dit comme l'a évoqué notre
président de gagner la guerre lorsque
l'état est perçue souvent comme
prédateur et non pas comme protecteur
nos forces et nous tenons à le rappeler
avec force et conviction font un travail
remarquable
et remporte de nombreuses victoires
parfois au prix du sacrifice suprême
malheureusement face à une certaine
forme de lâcheté des groupes armés
terroristes qui utilisent de plus en
plus régulièrement des yeux des ans ma
question est très directe madame la
ministre mais lorsque l'on connaît
l'intérêt de la turquie pour cette zone
du monde
n'y at il pas un lien entre
l'intensification de l'utilisation des
désirs des et l'arrivée notamment dans
le sud libyen de mercenaires syrien à la
solde de la turquie voilà merci merci
olivier alors ils avaient vraiment pas
verrou
très monsieur le président je me vois
bien entendu à l'hommage qui est rendu
aux soldats morts pour la france mais
surtout à nos soldats également de la
force par cannes qui ont il faut le dire
une parfaite maîtrise qui leur permet
d'accomplir des missions qui sont
délicates de grande intensité contre des
cibles de haute valeur en milieu extrême
avec des résultats
mais aujourd'hui nous sommes au coeur
d'une crise sanitaire économique inédite
et qui crée des rapports de force entre
les différents états dans de nouveaux
espaces et qui affaiblissent également
certains pays avec des inégalités des
peurs qui sont alimentés qui font le
berceau de changements souvent avec des
réactions d'une extrême violence
nous sommes aujourd'hui face à des choix
qui sont stratégiques et nous ne pouvons
pas laisser le champ libre aux groupes
armés terroristes
d'ailleurs le président l'avait dit il
ya un an les résultats qui sont obtenues
par nos forces conjuguées à
l'intervention plus importante de nos
partenaires européens vont nous
permettre de pouvoir ajuster nos efforts
ne croyez-vous pas madame la ministre
qu'il est aujourd'hui impératif
nécessaire de se donner les moyens de
communiquer d'insister davantage sur les
progrès malgré les pertes permis par
cette force et faire percevoir davantage
à l'opinion les enjeux de non
intervention militaire au sahel
face aux différentes interrogations de
la population
merci merci à ben alors richard yong
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
nos résultats militaires sont finalement
meilleures que ce que l'on dit et on a
porté des coups rudes aux différentes
aux différentes formations et en
particulier un nombre important de chefs
de différentes katiba et de différents
mouvements ont été tués mais on le sait
en fait nous combattons une forme de
guérilla se sont ce n'est pas une guerre
traditionnelle classique
vous avez un groupe de sept ou huit
personnes qui se promènent avec des hans
est en fait une katiba qui est déguisé
et nous devons nous devons faire face à
cela
donc le la victoire militaire est
difficile d'autant que les mouvements
que nous combattons sont multiples à
côté des deux grands que vous avez cité
le gsm et l'état islamique il y à une
foule de mouvements petits moyens qu'ils
ont tous des objectifs différents il ya
ceux qui veulent rétablir le califat
il ya ceux qui veulent l'indépendance de
l'azawad il ya ceux qui veulent créer
leur propre zone de d'activité etc etc
c'est donc difficile de trouver une voie
d'autant que pendant les huit années je
crois où il a été au pouvoir
ib cas que nous avons soutenu que tous
soutenu n'a rien fait politiquement faut
bien le dire les accords d'alger sont
resté quasiment lettre morte et les gens
du nord du mali ont raison de protester
contre le fait que rien n'a été fait
pour
alors voilà on a une situation de
militaires que je viens de décrire on a
une situation politique qui est bloqué
et pourtant on sait qu'à un moment donné
on devra discuter avec la partie adverse
négocier je ne sais pas mais discuter il
n'y a pas de conflit qui ne se résolvent
pas à travers une discussion
donc ma question madame la ministre
quels sont vos réflexions en la matière
merci richard je vais prendre deux
derniers intervenants pour cette
première salve hélène conway puis
yannick vaugrenard hélène et merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je m'associe bien sûr au nom de pas
personnellement et au nom de mon groupe
à l'hommage appuyé vous avez rendu au
sang versé par par nos soldats
bon aujourd'hui l'opération marque anne
n'est pas une opération de défense au de
protection de territoire mais de
l'affaiblissement d'un ennemi que vous
avez nommés très clairement dans une
opération dans laquelle nous nous
rencontrons certain succès encourageant
depuis quelques temps notre collègue
richard young vient de rappeler est donc
le moment n'est peut-être pas forcément
opportun de parler de désengagement qui
pourrait finalement redonné espoir à
notre ennemi un moment où nous pourrions
être en position de force
en même temps il est naturel qu'après 8
en engagement croissant avec un coût
très important nous ayons un débat une
réflexion ici aujourd'hui et le 9
février dans l'hémicycle alors
j'aimerais vous questionner sur les
équipements et le dire que peut-être
nous pourrions être présent mais
présente différemment
c'est peut-être que le président de la
république a souhaité annoncer hier dans
les voeux qu'il a présentés aux armées
puisque il a dit que l'effort de bach
canal être ajustés sais pas si vous
pouvez peut-être le donner quelques
indications savoir comment cela va se
traduire dans les fêtes et aussi
pourquoi maintenant dont cédric perrin a
soulevé la question essentielle du
blindage et d'insécurité de nos vbl
l'utilisation des drones aussi notamment
d'une tactique patroller vrai je
voudrais simplement vous questionner sur
nos moyens de renseignement est ce que
ceux ci vont être augmentés renforcer
nos moyens de liaison et aussi de
détection des idées par image et
imagerie
radar qui fait l'objet de l'étude depuis
déjà quelques années
et enfin nous avons deux avions légers
de surveillance et de reconnaissance qui
ont été livrées à evreux en août et en
décembre 2020 donc j'aimerais savoir si
et quand ils seront déployés
et quand seront ils opérationnels sur le
théâtre sahélien je remercie
merci m yannick vaugrenard pour terminer
cette première série merci monsieur le
président merci madame la ministre de
ces compléments d'information que vous
nous avez apporté cet après midi je
pense que peu d'entre nous se serait
imaginé ou à 6 8 ans que nous serions
encore présent peut-être au sahel
aujourd'hui avec 57 tués qui sont morts
pour que nous puissions continuer de
vivre le plus librement possible s'était
rappelée par hélène tout de suite le
président de la république à l'occasion
des voeux aux armées à brest a utilisé
le terme que le fait que les efforts
militaires de la france dans la région
allait être ajustée la question qu à ce
moment là que nous pouvons nous poser
c'est sous quelles conditions
ou est-ce que c'est quoi qu'il en coûte
2e
le questionnement c'est par rapport à ce
qu'a dit voici quelques temps le général
lecointe qui nécessitent je crois de la
part de la france peut-être de vous même
une explication générale coin disait la
chose suivante il ya effectivement un
positionnement de principe de la france
qui considère que ne négocie pas avec
des terroristes mais il faudra bien
trouver une solution politique ce que
chacun conçoit depuis le début de ce
conflit
pour moi ce n'est pas une question
morale on ne pourra pas faire la paix au
mali sans audace de réconciliation bien
sûr là où je suis interrogatif c'est
qu'ils rajoutent qui dépassent les
critères occidentaux
donc ça a été rappelé tout à l'heure il
faut tout faire pour que les dieux à 10
ne reprennent par le pouvoir
quelles sont les formes de
réconciliation qui dépasserait les
critères occidentaux
je vous pouvez me répondre à la ministre
voilà on est des questions assez
précises auxquelles je vous propose de
répondre si vous le voulez bien
préférence global regroupés comme vous
le souhaitez lien pour commencer
peut-être un point de méthodes monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je ne suis pas certain de pouvoir
répondre à toutes vos questions
aujourd'hui dans la mesure où vous
l'avez noté
il y a un rendez vous très important
avec le sommet de n'djamena et je pense
que ce n'est pas du tout faire injure au
parlement que de dire que ces questions
doivent d'abord être partagées avec les
pays concernés je les dis dans mon
propos liminaire c'est à leur demande
que nous sommes présents
donc c'est aussi au terme d'un échange
certes la discussion et
permanente mais je crois que à un an
après le sommet de peau c'est une
discussion d'une nature très formelle
est importante que qui aura lieu
et donc je ne pourrais je préfère vous
le dire d'emblée vous donner des détails
sur des ajustements qui ont vocation à
faire l'objet de discussions avec tout
d'abord nos partenaires sahéliens et
bien sûr nos partenaires européens
donc ce n'est pas mauvaise volonté de ma
part
je suis évidemment à votre disposition
dès que ce sommet aura eu lieu pour que
nous rédigions je crois que la date de
notre débat permettra de le faire mais
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas en situation
de partager avec vous ce qui de notre
côté ne peut relever que de réflexion
qui doivent faire l'objet d'une échange
d'un échange avec nos partenaires un
sahélien et européens
cela étant dit
je vais quand même mais force est de
répondre au reste alors tout d'abord il
me semble avoir couvert un certain
nombre de vos questions monsieur le
président dans le cadre de mon
intervention liminaire il ya aussi un
certain nombre de considérations que
vous avez évoquées et qu' on ne peut que
pleinement partagée en particulier la
difficulté à laquelle nous avons tous
été confrontés de ne pas pouvoir nous
appuyer sur un accords d'alger mises en
oeuvre pendant toutes ces années la
nécessité de pouvoir s'appuyer sur une
véritable volonté politique pour pouvoir
avancer à défaut de quoi nous avancer
sur le plan militaire n'ont pas
l'efficacité que celle ci pourrait avoir
j'ai aussi entendu de votre part le
regret que
et cela remonte à des temps plus anciens
certains territoires notamment dans la
partie nord du mali finalement rarement
eu des contacts avec l'état malien et
donc c'est un problème si je puis dire
historique et structurelles qui
s'ajoutent à une difficulté qui est
celle que nous connaissons c'est à dire
la propagation du terrorisme dans la
région
donc sur tous ces éléments là je partage
pleinement vos constats et donc j'en
viens aux questions
que vous avez posé tout d'abord sur la
protection de nos forces
c'est évidemment une préoccupation
absolument majeur nous qui prend
plusieurs qui prend plusieurs formes
vous l'avez dit le fait que nous
puissions disposer de drones désormais
armée et un est un acquis est un plus
tout à fait considérable je ne sais pas
si nous sommes trop discret en toujours
est il que du jour où le premier drone
c'était il ya c'était en décembre 2019 a
été utilisé
cela a élargi amplifier notre nos
capacités en propre sur le terrain c'est
indéniable
nous avons en effet de nouveaux drones
qui sont arrivés sur le théâtre libyen
est tout et c'est aujourd'hui pour que
l'ensemble des certificats validation
autorisations de vol puisse être donnée
afin de pouvoir tirer pleinement parti
de ces matériels sur le retard qui a été
pris en matière de drones c'est un
retard européen vous le savez tous ce
retard a vocation à être comblés
pour ce qui concerne les drôles mal
parlera aux drones mais en attendant
nous avons
pris un certain nombre d'initiatives en
particulier l'armée de terre sera livrée
très prochainement de drones de petites
de petite taille qui vont nous aider à
compléter
même si ça ne remplace pas évidemment un
drone mâle mais il ya un vocation à
compléter notre notre panneau qu au delà
de 100 la question du blindage dans un
contexte de multiplication des attaques
par ed est évidemment je n'ose pas dire
reposer parce qu'elle est posée sans
cesse il y a eu ces derniers jours
compte tenu des événements tragiques
auxquels nous avons été confrontés une
sorte de coup de projecteur qui a été
donnée sur ces attaques par engin
explosif improvisé
mais je n'ai pas à les planches avec moi
mais si je vous montrais le nombre d'
attaques qui ont été réalisés en 2019 et
2020 et qui ont touché d'abord les
forces armées sahélienne et les
populations civiles
nous ne sommes pas du tout dans les
mêmes ordres de grandeur et c'est
terrible à dire
donc ce sont ce sont des attaques
quotidiennes
ce sont des attaques quotidiennes et non
discriminés néanmoins c'est un sujet
majeur pour la protection de nos soldats
donc il y a plusieurs initiatives qui
doivent se conjuguer
la première vous l'avez évoqué c'est le
fait de pouvoir renforcer le blindage ou
la protection des matériels qui sont
actuellement disponibles aux salles donc
s'agissant en dvd elle marque un des
kits de blindage ont été commandés pas
en 2016 monsieur sénateur ou alors on
parle pas des mêmes ils ont été
commandés en 2018 ils sont en train
d'être
livret pardon je reprends ses kits c'est
bien ça sont en train d'être livrés et
par conséquent les vbl marque un ainsi
renforcées seront acheminés sur le
théâtre sahélien par voie aérienne au
cours du premier semestre 2021 nous
faisons tous vous l'avez compris pour
que ce soit le plus rapide possible et
en particulier le fait qu'on
l'acheminement par voie aérienne est
fait pour gagner du temps par rapport à
un acheminement par voie maritime et
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour dire
monsieur le sénateur cadic que j'ai bien
pris note de ce qui a été dit sur douala
et j'en ferai évidemment pas à mon
collègue c'était une parenthèse parce
que c'est effectivement tout ce qui
transite par voie maritime peut être
affectée par cette intention
il y à d'autres décisions qui ont été
prises pour améliorer la protection
contre les yeux d il s'agit des bébés
elle 10 ultime
ce sont des bébés elle qui ont des
structures également renforcé les
premières livraisons sont attendues pour
le début de l'année prochaine
on voit bien donc ce n'est pas une
solution si je puis dire
à très court terme et donc le avec le
chef d'état major des armées nous avons
dansé une réflexion pour essayer de
modifier également usage qui est fait
des véhicules blindés légers qui reste
des véhicules comme leurs noms
l'indiquent blindés et léger donc au
delà de renforcement des structures il y
à une réflexion à conduire rapide
il s'agit pas d'une réflexion au long
cours pour essayer
porter une meilleure protection à nos
militaires je n'ai pas connaissance de
je n'ai pas connaissance de ces aimants
donc plutôt que de vous dire des choses
1 précise je vais donc les vérifier il
ya par ailleurs des travaux qui relèvent
encore de l'innovation ou de la
recherche développement certains ont été
cités la détection par radar des
modifications qui peuvent être apportées
sur le terrain il y à d'autres
réflexions qui sont en cours bref nous
voyons bien que il faut maintenant
forcer le rythme parce que parce que
c'est une question qui est trop grave et
que la multiplication de ces idées et
est un signal qui aussi nous en dit long
sur le message que diffusent ces
organisations terroristes vous avez vu
qu'elle est la communication dont ils
ont accompagné les les dernières
attaques meurtrières
ils l'ont revendiquée et c'est une
invitation qui est fait à la france pour
quitter le théâtre ça il ya donc comme
nous n'allons pas nous faire dicter
notre comportement par ces injonctions
émises par des groupes terroristes
il nous faut mettre sous les atouts de
notre côté et assurer la protection la
protection de la force donc
je pense que nous serons en mesure dans
le courant de l'année 2021 d'apporter
des innovations à la manière de ceux de
se protéger contre ces idées
malheureusement vous savez tout ce qui
n'existe pas de remède absolu
nous avons déjà sur d'autres théâtres en
d'autres temps subi ce genre d' attaque
mais je peux vous dire pour avoir visité
avec peut-être sur certains d'entre vous
à satory il ya quelques jours le battle
la paire qu' il y a un certain nombre
d'outils d'innovation qui sont quasiment
en situation d'être déployés sur le
terrain il faut passer de l'innovation
au déploiement c'est toujours le défi
auquel nous sommes confrontés
[Musique]
autre question concernant la menace yeux
des nous en avons parlé cbbl nous en
avons parlé
peut-être dans le désordre sur la
nécessité de communiquer plus sur nos
résultats au sahel
je partage complètement ce point de vue
et d'ailleurs je vous remercie puisque
cette cette audition et le et pour moi
l'opportunité de commencer de le faire
nous sommes dans une situation
paradoxale puisque un an après le sommet
de pau on voit bien la situation
sécuritaire s'est améliorée alors il
faut évidemment être toujours très
prudent dans la manière dont on qualifie
les choses mais madame la sénatrice vous
l'avez dit il y a il ya des éléments
d'amélioration
la concentration de nos efforts dans la
zone des trois frontières a permis
d'entamer assez significativement les
capacités des groupes armés terroristes
en particulier celui qui était notre
cible principale c'est-à-dire l'état
islamique au grand cerf
par ailleurs les forces armées locales
je les dis ont beaucoup progressé et
j'en veux pour preuve que les opérations
bourrasques et éclipse qui éclipse qui
est l'opération
siph sur les forces armées locales
et puis enfin je lui ai dit tout à
l'heure nos partenaires européens sont
de plus en plus nombreux à nous
accompagner et pourtant et pourtant on a
le sentiment que c'est le moment qui a
été choisi pour dire qu'au fond rien de
tout cela ne marche les commentateurs
font preuve d'un très grand scepticisme
présente même le mali comme étant notre
afghanistan alors moi je ne veux pas
commenter tel ou tel sondage mais il me
semble que les français dans leur
ensemble soutiennent nos militaires ils
les soutiennent fortement et pour une
raison je crois très simple c'est qu'ils
ont pleinement conscience que les
militaires contribuer à les protéger
donc non le mali ce n'est pas
l'afghanistan un je les dis dans mon
propos liminaire nous ne sommes pas
englué dans une guerre éternelle est à
nouveau je pense que le sommet ne neige
amène à devrait être l'occasion de
permettre de dresser ce bilan de le
faire de manière très public est très
officielle avec nos partenaires ça il ya
zoo et européen et je pense qu'avec vous
tous parlementaires membres des
commissions de la défense de l'assemblée
nationale du sénat les commissions des
affaires étrangères pour ce qui concerne
l'assemblée nationale c'est notre
mission que de contribuer à faire
connaître ses avancées ses résultats
[Musique]